habe windows 19 linux vm da geht kein pitch networking bei einer windows 10 vm geht alles
also bei den gleichen settings sollte es eigentlich überhaupt keinen unterschied
machen kann das sein dass dein linux einfach nicht versucht eine ip zu bekommen kann das
sein also dass das prinzipiell geht aber du keine ip automatisch bekommst was ist denn
wenn du versuchst mal von hand eine ip dem interface zu geben und gateway zu setzen geht
es dann ansonsten ist es prima zu diagnostizieren schwierig so aber mal zur zum heutigen stream wie
gesagt ich weiß nicht wie lange das ganze geht ich mache das vor allem hauptsächlich erstmal
dass ich selbst im überblick bekomme was gibt es für neue intel cpu was gibt es für für mainboards
dafür es gibt von ms von msi habe ich gesehen so ein richtiges weihnachtsbaum mainboards
das ist wirklich bunter als der weihnachtsbaum gucken uns das an und ich habe so ein paar
anforderungen die ich von dem mainboard brauche und ich habe auch so ein paar sachen die ich
halt mit dem pc machen will wo er sich gut vereignen sollte deswegen müssen wir uns das
ganze jetzt mal angucken das hätte ich eh gemacht deswegen strebe ich das ganze jetzt
mal weil ich denke mal das interessiert noch mehr leute aber ich habe kein wasser das ist
schlimm weil ich habe irgendwie so viel aber brauche ich immer ein wasser zum trinken captain
seeker ich würde dir vorschlagen je nachdem was du installiert hast neben den network manager
oder so was ist es nicht so wichtig was du installiert hast nimm den network manager oder
sowas ist es nicht so wichtig was du installiert hast nimm den network manager oder sowas ist
irgendwas wo du von hand einen gui hast wo du ip und subnet mask und gateway und dns und so eintragen
kannst also was ich aktuell für den rechner habe vielleicht noch mal zur erklärung aktuell habe
ich einen xeon 1032 v3 den habe ich mir gekauft kann ich nämlich zeigen weil ich habe dazu ein
video gemacht deswegen weiß ich das noch mein neuer rechner was ist
drin das habe ich gekauft von wann ist das video hier 16 der oktober 2013 habe ich den alten rechner
verkauft ich habe auch irgendwo hier eine anzeige was drinnen war an dem rechner damals also sprich
da ist ein xeon 1032 v3 drin das sind das hat 4 x 3,3 gigahertz damals zwar socl 1115 0
da habe ich 16 gigabyte ddr3 rahmen den kann ich auf jeden fall nicht verwenden das war jetzt schon
ein 580 watt be quiet netzteil und ein mainboard so was ich davon wieder was ich davon weiter
verwenden werde ist die grafiker habe ich auch nicht mehr da habe ich mittlerweile 1080 ti und
hier fest und hierzu ssd habe ich zusätzlich noch zwei terabyte ssd aber das schreiben wir
uns gleich noch mal auf was ich hier von weiter verwenden werden ist definitiv das gehäuse das
ist das beste gehäuse das beste pc gehäuse was ich je hatte das ist das hier was ist das hier
da gibt es mittlerweile schon nachfolger für gibt es da gibt es schon r6 gibt es nicht da
gibt es nachfolge aber das sehe ich nicht ein ich sehe es mir nicht wozu sollte ich mir neues
gehäuse kauft das gehäuse ist wirklich extrem geil das beste gehäuse was ich je hatte das ist
das ist ein bisschen breiter als als normalerweise aber so von der verarbeitung her allem ist das
wirklich dass das das beste gehäuse und ich sehe keinen grund mir neues gehäuse zu kaufen einfach
nur weil ich mir nur ein rechner kaufe ist ja auch bescheuert irgendwo ja aber wobei
wozu ja ich bauen neuen rechner und ich wollte mir schon lange neue rechner kaufen ich habe
schon darauf gewartet dass hier nur intel cpu raus kommen letzte mal dachte ich noch eher amd aber
nachdem ich heute die benchmarks und das ganze zeug gesehen habe tendiere ich mittlerweile wieder eher
zu intern ob das jetzt die finale zusammenstellung ist die wir heute uns ausdenken das muss ich noch
mal zeigen aber ich will wie gesagt selbst erstmal gucken also das gehäuse habe ich zur zeit das heißt
Wir schreiben uns das jetzt mal kurz auf.
Medicaid, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Ich habe es nur ganz kurz überflogen vorhin.
Also, schreiben wir das mal auf.
Ich mache die Schriftart mal ein bisschen größer.
Neuer PC.
Also, wir haben ein Fractal.
Moment, wie ging das?
Wie konnte man die Schriftart größer machen?
Da gab es irgendwie so eine komische Konfig-Datei.
Das war eigentlich ziemlich simpel.
Genau, so.
Kann man ziemlich einfach sagen,
Font, Editor Font Size ist 20.
Aber dann sieht man das nämlich auch ganz gut.
Ja, na, wir können auch ein bisschen größer machen.
Machen wir 24.
Also, was wir haben, ist auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, noch ein Fractal Design R4.
Das behalte ich auch, weil, geiles Gehäuse.
Gibt es nichts zu sagen.
Das behalte ich auf jeden Fall.
Das heißt, das muss ich nicht neu kaufen.
So, und das ist alt.
Das habe ich noch.
So.
Dann habe ich auch noch,
Kein RGB Mist, nee, ich hasse RGB Beleuchtung.
Bei neuen Mainboards werde ich leider nicht dazu jetzt dran vorbeikommen.
Ja, weil die haben alle irgendwelche Lichter und so dran.
Mir geht es ja bei der Grafikkarte schon auf den Keks, dass die leuchtet.
Hallo Nielsen.
Übrigens Nielsen, unser Beratungsvideo müssen wir noch machen.
Ich verschaffe mir hier gerade noch mal einen Überblick.
Falls ich Mist erzähle, schreibt das ruhig in den Chat rein.
Ähm, ich habe nämlich selbst noch keine Ahnung von der neuen Generation, so wirklich.
Mal gucken, was es so alles gibt.
Also, ein Fractal Design R4 habe ich noch.
Das behalte ich auch.
Ähm, meine, meine, ähm, meine 512 GB Samsung SSD behalte ich natürlich auch.
Und die 2 TB behalte ich natürlich auch.
Das wäre ja bescheuert.
Dann habe ich noch eine 6 TB WD irgendwas.
Die behalte ich natürlich auch, weil, warum sollte ich die wegschmeißen?
Das wäre ja auch total beknackt.
So, wichtig ist, dann hatte ich einen, dann hatte ich einen 580 Watt, ne, 500 was?
Wo ist das?
Das hatte ich.
Das behalte ich auch.
Ziehe ich nicht ein, das auszutauschen.
Und.
Die einzige, und dann habe ich natürlich noch ne, ne, ne GTX 1080 TI.
Die bleibt natürlich auch.
So, das heißt, im Prinzip brauchen wir eigentlich nur neu.
Wir brauchen eine CPU.
Wir brauchen ein Mainboard.
Und wir brauchen eine RAM.
RAM habe ich zwar noch.
Habe ich noch 16 GB DDR3.
Aber.
Das geht nicht.
Kann man hier.
WTF8X, was auch immer, gibt es da nicht irgendein schönes, ein X-Mark wollen wir haben.
Genau, ein X-Mark.
Den können wir nicht mehr verwenden.
Der ist für den Arsch.
So, wo ich mir jetzt überhaupt nicht sicher bin.
Ist der Kühler.
Das ist noch ein normales SATA SSD.
Flogsig.
Beides, beides.
Äh, Ende 2018 soll schon DDR5 rauskommen, habe ich gehört.
Ja, pff.
Ich denke mir da mittlerweile.
Guck mal da, Felix, was macht der hier?
PC schneller hochfahren.
Ah, okay, der macht, äh, Kingston Kampagne.
Warum nicht, kann man machen.
Ähm, das einzige, wo ich mir nicht sicher bin, ist.
Was mit meinem CPU-Kühler ist.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht weiß der Nilsson das.
Weil der Kühler, der geht eigentlich für, äh, den Sockel.
Schreiben die vielleicht auch mal irgendwo, was der alles unterstützt.
Haben wir keinen Bock drauf.
Es ist ja auch für den Lüfter vollkommen unwichtig, was der für Plattformen unterstützt, ne.
Weil, wer muss das schon wissen, das ist ja.
Also, ich hab mal vorhin geguckt, der kann die Plattform, theoretisch.
Genau, also, theoretisch müsste mein alter Lüfter auch funktionieren.
Da kommt einfach ein bisschen Wärmeleitpaste drunter und gut ist.
Da muss ich aber nochmal genau gucken.
Sogar der Nilsson sagt, das würde auch funktionieren.
Muss ich mir aber nochmal, da muss ich mir sicher sein, ob das wirklich passt.
Weil sonst, ne, es gibt nichts frustrierender, wenn ich mir eine CPU kaufe, ein Mainboard kaufe, RAM kaufe.
Alles ausgebaut hab aus dem Rechner, alles neu eingebaut hab in das Gehäuse.
Und dann feststelle, der Lüfter passt nicht richtig.
Ja, dass der Abstand und so passt, ist klar.
Das ist mir klar, dass da theoretisch auch das Mainboard passen müsste.
Ähm.
Ich weiß halt nicht, wie es mit, wie es mit Kühlleistung aussieht und mit.
Es gab ja mal vor einer Weile das Gerücht, dass ähm, ältere Lüfter bei Skylake CPUs die CPU verformen würden oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung, ob da jemals was dran gewesen ist.
Hab ich vor einer Weile gelesen.
Weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich stimmt das nicht.
Blödsinn, ne.
Wie, das ist ja kein Bulldozer.
Ha, lol, AMD-Joke.
Ne, aber das, äh, muss ihn halt schön reinnehmen.
Ja klar muss der Lüfter sauber gemacht werden vorher.
Aber das Schöne daran ist.
Aber das Schöne ist, dass das Gehäuse hat, ähm, also kommt kaum Staub rein.
Ähm, ab und zu, wenn ich den, wenn ich den alten Rechner mal aufmache.
Um, was auch immer, irgendwas.
Letztes Mal habe ich die 1080Ti eingebaut, ja.
Da ist fast null Staub drin.
Das Gehäuse ist echt geil.
Das Gehäuse ist wirklich gut.
Gucken wir mal, auch mal auf YouTube.
Also das Gehäuse kann ich euch nur empfehlen, wenn ihr ein Gehäuse sucht.
Ich meine, ich würde mir da natürlich das, äh, das 5er kaufen.
Ich würde mir, ich würde mir jetzt nicht mehr das alte Gehäuse kaufen.
Aber vielleicht sieht man hier mal ein paar Bilder von dem, von dem Gehäuse.
Das ist halt echt gut.
Das ist wirklich geil.
Da hast du Staubfilter drin.
Hast du, hast, theoretisch hast du auch eine Lüftersteuerung oben, die ich nicht brauche, weil ich keine extra Lüfter drin hab.
Ähm, hast Staubfilter.
Hast hier, kannst hier eine SSD.
Kannst hier hinten eine SSD machen, die du dann hier vorne rausführen kannst.
Das heißt, du hast hier vorne alles frei für, äh, Festplatten.
Man kann die Festplatten, weil es schräg eingebaut ist, auch relativ alt machen.
Einfach wechseln.
Also fast wie einen Hotswap-Rahmen.
Fast, fast, ja.
Das ist nicht Hotswap, weil ist halt nix dran.
Aber das ist wirklich gut.
Ähm, ups.
Äh, ich hab's, ich hab's mit Fenster, das Gehäuse.
So.
Aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal die neuen Sachen an.
Und zwar habe ich heute gelesen, einmal auf GoLearn und einmal auf Computerbase.
Ich glaube, die haben beide Benchmarks zu den neuen, zu den neuen CPUs.
Und da muss ich jetzt mal durchscrollen, wo das hier gewesen ist.
Und da sieht man, dass die neuen Intel-CPUs gegen, ähm, die schnellsten Ryzen-CPUs ziemlich gut abschneiden.
Zwar nicht im...
Wo haben wir denn hier Benchmarks?
Okay, wir müssen uns mal durchklicken, bis wir, bis wir bei Benchmarks sind.
Übrigens Computerbase ist immer so eine super Seite, wenn man sich über neue Hardware-Sachen informieren will.
Hat ein...
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, Computerbase hat hier unten immer so einen, so einen Dropdown.
Das gibt...
Ach nee, hier oben ist das.
Ja.
Hauptsache mal gemeckert.
Also...
Genau.
Äh...
Man sieht in der Gesamtanwendung...
Also wenn man sich jetzt mal hier Cinebench anguckt zum Beispiel, oder Cine...
Wie spricht man das eigentlich aus?
Cinebench?
Ähm...
Das ist natürlich rein CPU in your face, ja?
Da dürfte der Ryzen natürlich noch vorne sein.
Aber auch nicht viel.
Man muss sich mal überlegen.
Der...
Der neue Intel i7-8700K in dem Fall.
Der hat 6 Kerne.
Und...
Der Ryzen hat glaube ich 8.
Genau.
Der hat 8.
Also das heißt, in einem CPU-Benchmark, wo es rein...
Also rein so synthetische...
Wir testen einfach, wie schnell es geht parallelisierbar in your face, ja?
Da ist klar, dass der Ryzen natürlich seine 2 Kerne mehr ausspielen kann.
Aber dafür, muss man sagen, ähm...
Hält sich das jetzt ja auch in Grenzen.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass der...
Der Ryzen...
Also ich habe irgendwo gelesen, dass in Games natürlich die Intel-CPU wieder ganz gut, ziemlich einen Vorsprung hat.
Ich suche jetzt bloß gerade die Benchmarks dazu.
Hier haben die welche dabei gehabt, ne.
Ach ja, was ich mit dem Rechner machen will.
Also ne, muss ich vorher auch immer mal überlegen, was will man mit dem Rechner machen.
Bei mir ist das ganz einfach.
Ich will erstmal spielen.
Das ist quasi Must-Have.
Was schneller ist in Spielen, ist wahrscheinlich auch besser für mich.
Danach will ich natürlich Stream rendern.
Das ist das nächste.
Aber ich behaupte mal, dass alle Rechner, die man sich so zusammenstellen kann, die richtig gut in aktuellen Spielen sind, auch locker reichen zum Rendern und Streamen.
Klar, theoretisch ist für Rendern und Streamen mehr Kerne.
Potenziell besser als weniger Kerne, aber wenn man einen Rechner hat, der schnell genug ist, für aktuelle Games, ist es auf jeden Fall schnell genug.
Zumal ich GPU-Encoding für den Stream verwende und dass meine CPU eh nicht weiter juckt.
Für YouTube verwende ich ganz normal das H.264 mit FFmpeg, das über die CPU.
Da würden vielleicht die zwei Kerne vom Ryzen ein bisschen was bringen, aber die Renderzeit, das wird...
Das wird es nicht dick ausmachen.
Also im Prinzip sind das eigentlich meine Hauptanwendungszwecke.
Ich will spielen, ich will streamen und rendern.
Was ich nicht will, ist 3D bearbeiten.
Also 3D, ja sowas wie Blender oder so, will ich nicht machen.
Oder schreibe mal, keine 3D-Models.
So Blender oder so Dinge will ich nicht machen, ist nicht meins.
Also das heißt, ob die jetzt irgendwie eine gescheite OpenGL-Implikation...
Implementierung haben für die Grafikkarte, ist mir egal, zumal ich eh schon eine Grafikkarte habe.
Im Prinzip war es das eigentlich schon, weil natürlich will ich so Dinger machen wie surfen, Mails schreiben, bla bla bla.
Aber ehrlich, ein Rechner, der das hier oben kann, der hat keine Probleme mit Mails.
Ich will auf jeden Fall, das ist noch eine wichtige, 2-3 Bildschirme will ich haben.
Wobei das meine Grafikkarte auch kann, überhaupt kein Ding.
Und was ich unbedingt brauche, ist optischer Sound.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Das muss ich unbedingt haben.
So, gucken wir nochmal ein paar PC-Games.
Hardware, was die so am Start haben.
Ich brauche unbedingt einen optischen Soundausgang.
Für mein Audio-Interface.
Ups.
Alter, Werbung, piss dich, Alde.
Der Name sagt mir irgendwas.
Den kenne ich, der Name kommt mir bekannt vor.
Könnte sein, da stehen wir auf der...
Wie sieht der Typ aus?
Habe ich den mal auf der Gamescom getroffen?
Der kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Irgendwie kommt er mir bekannt vor.
Okay.
Die haben Spiele-Benchmarks.
Intel Unlimited.
Yeah.
So, aber gucken wir uns erstmal die Computer-Base-Seite fertig an.
Also klar, hier kann natürlich der Ryzen das ein bisschen ausspielen.
Bei Caseking, vielleicht kenne ich den noch.
Keine Ahnung.
Mit Caseking hatte ich ja nicht wirklich viel zu tun.
Okay.
Ja, was man hier noch als Anforderung draufschreiben kann, ist natürlich Video-Beratung.
Aber das dürfte durch meine SSD schon mal ganz gut abgedeckt sein.
Dass Vegas nicht hängt.
So, was haben die sonst noch für Benchmarks?
Ah, das ist auch ganz interessant.
Also man sieht, das Ding haut schon rein, ja.
So.
Gesamt-Rating Linux.
Ha!
Guck uns das Ganze ja gerade unter Linux an.
Okay, hier gibt es nochmal einen Unigine Valley Benchmark.
Da ist der auch ganz vorne mit dabei.
Aber man sieht hier schon, bei Spielen waren ja die Ryzens jetzt zwar immer nicht zu langsam,
aber auch schon die letzte Generation nicht vorne mit dabei.
Okay.
Also aktuell tendiere ich eindeutig zu dem Ding.
Der kostet, glaube ich, um die 400 Euro.
Nein.
Und ist natürlich noch nicht lieferbar, ist ja klar, ne.
Das Netzteil, also weil ich gerade Diskussionen lese über das Netzteil, 580 Watt Netzteil, das reicht.
Die Zeiten von 1000 Watt Netzteilen und Netzteil-Schwanzvergleich sind vorbei.
Seit 8 Jahren oder so.
Genau.
Also die CPU kostet mich 400 Euro.
Die CPU kostet mich 400 Euro.
Also, so, da gucken wir uns nochmal die Benchmarks von...
Spiele-Benchmarks mit...
Gucken wir uns mal...
PC-Games-Hardware ist auch immer super, was sowas angeht.
So, Crysis 3.
Ich finde es geil, dass Crysis 3 immer noch genommen wird.
Da sieht man, dass sich grafisch, also beziehungsweise von...
...der Entwicklung her...
Ich kann ja jetzt auch nicht mehr so rasend schnell fahren, weil es geht wie früher.
Äh, Max, was ist wichtiger, CPU oder Grafikkarte für möglichst hohe FPS?
Das kommt auf das Game an.
Prinzipiell, so.
Das kann man, das kann man doch nicht mal prinzipiell sagen.
Also, normal würde ich sagen, wenn die CPU halbwegs aktuell ist und deine Grafikkarte mega scheiße,
dann eine Grafikkarte.
Aber wenn du eh schon eine ganz gute Grafikkarte hast,
hast du eine mega scheiße CPU.
Das kommt, also es kommt aufs Game an und es muss halt zueinander passen.
Es muss halt zueinander passen.
Also, ich würde sagen, so aus dem Bauch raus, würde ich sagen,
je höher die Auflösung und quasi die Qualitätsstufe im Game,
ähm, je wichtiger die Grafikkarte, wobei man das auch nicht pauschal sagen kann,
ähm, weil die Grafikkarte ja auch von der CPU noch anständig was bekommen muss.
Also, wenn man sich zum Beispiel PUBG anguckt,
das ist ein Game, das ist, äh, nicht sonder-, also, es ist nicht sonderlich hübsch.
Das, ich würde sagen, ich würde nicht sagen, dass es die Grafikkarte gar nicht fordert,
aber, ähm, das braucht ordentlich CPU.
Und wenn dann eine CPU nicht hinterherkommt,
dann bringt ja auch eine schnelle Grafikkarte nix.
Du hast, du hast andere Games, ähm, zum Beispiel, das ist das neue Doom,
das flutscht auch bei langsamer CPU besser.
PUBG ist da halt so negativ.
Beispiel von.
Kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Es muss, es muss zueinander passen.
Also, es hat keinen Sinn, wenn du jetzt irgendwie hier so eine Einsteiger-CPU holst und 1080 Ti.
Das, das muss, das muss irgendwie zusammenpassen.
Dann kann es nämlich gut sein, dass du die, die, die, die volle Stärke deiner 1080 Ti gar nicht ausspielen kannst.
Und zumal, und bei mir ist es ja so, äh, ich stelle ja oftmals eh schon
äh,
die Grafik und so lieber runter, dass ich mehr FPS hab.
Also, ich will, ich, ich hab einen 144-Hertz-Monitor schon seit, seit es den geheimen gibt,
weil ich es einfach für eine der besten Erfindungen der letzten Jahre halte in der Richtung.
Ähm,
und,
ich hätte, ich hätte, ich hätte am liebsten Minimum 144 FPS,
eher mehr, sodass quasi, wenn es mal droppt, es quasi nicht unter 144 FPS droppt.
Deswegen stelle ich meistens die Grafik, so, bei Offerboard spiele ich auf fast minimal Settings.
Außer Render-Scale und sowas.
Einfach, das muss flutschen, mehr FPS, gleich besser, ganz einfach.
Mein alter PC war damals ziemlich gut.
Preis-Leistungs-mäßig und auch von der Performance.
Ja, und mein Xeon ist in die Jahre gekommen, deswegen gucke ich jetzt ja auch gerade nach einer neuen CPU.
Man muss aber sagen, mein Xeon ist nicht scheiße, auch aus heutiger Sicht nicht.
So in, sagen wir mal so, Single, Single-Core-Singles-Wert-Performance oder, oder Performance mit, mit 1, 2,
Kern, 3, Kern, was auch immer, ja, was für Games relevant ist oder, sagen wir mal, 4,
ist der Xeon immer noch ziemlich gut dabei.
Es ist nicht so, dass der jetzt total scheiße wäre und die 1080 Ti deswegen rumkrebsen würde.
So schlimm ist der gar nicht.
So, also gucken wir uns jetzt hier nochmal die Spiele, die Spiele-Benchmarks an.
Vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt in 1280, hä, gibt's da vielleicht noch, gibt's da noch ein bisschen mehr?
Ja.
Was ich nicht verstehe es, ist, warte mal, ist weniger besser oder mehr besser?
Mehr ist besser, ne?
Was ich jetzt hier nicht wirklich checke, ist, warum ist denn der i7, 7740X, was auch immer,
das für einer jetzt genau gewesen ist.
Warum ist der schneller
in StarCraft als
der hier?
Das leuchtet mir nicht so ganz an. Der Takt bei dem
hier ist... Na, der Takt ist
vielleicht höher
im Durchschnitt dann. Keine Ahnung.
Zumindest ist der oben mit dabei.
Ryzen kackt hier ein bisschen ab
dabei. Aber StarCraft 2
ist relativ CPU-intensiv.
Äh, Cooper, ich hab mir bis vor...
bis letzte Woche
hab ich mir noch überlegt,
ob ich mir nicht einen Ryzen kaufe.
Aber ich muss sagen,
die neue Intel-Plattform überzeugt mich
von den Sachen, die ich heute gelesen hab.
Witcher 3
haut es auch richtig rein.
Ähm, und
ein Game, was ich garantiert nicht spielen werde,
ist das auch gut dabei.
Also die CPU scheint mir schon eine gute
Wahl zu sein.
Was jetzt aber viel interessanter wird. Also ich würde sagen,
die CPU ist gesetzt.
CPU gibt auf jeden Fall
gibt's... gibt's so hier einen.
Ich mein, ich hab ja auch genug Budget.
Hätte ich eh, aber
zumal ich jetzt noch nicht mal
die andere Hälfte von dem Rechner brauche,
weil ich die Teile noch hab.
Also CPU wird ziemlich sicher so einer.
Das kostet um die 400 Euro.
Ähm,
und ich... also die Benchmarks
geben dem Ding ja auch recht.
Wenn man sich anguckt, ähm,
der schnellste...
Moment.
Hallo, Maus.
Also der
ist
30...
30 Prozent, 33 Prozent
schneller als der schnellste
Weißen. In dem Fall jetzt hier
in Crysis 3. Also für Gaming
und das ist ja auch meine erste Anforderung,
was ich hier gestellt hab.
Spiele ist das Wichtigste.
Gefolgt von den anderen Sachen
ist das schon eine gute Wahl.
Was viel komplizierter wird jetzt, sind
Mainboards für das Ding.
Da hab ich nämlich noch gar keine Ahnung,
was es alles gibt.
Das gucken wir jetzt nämlich mal auf Geizhals,
was es da alles für Mainboards gibt.
Ich weiß so, dass es von MSI so Weihnachtsbaum...
Wenn ich das schon wieder sehe hier...
Ach nee, das ist ein Z...
Das ist gar nicht richtig, ein Mainboard.
Ähm, Mainboards gibt's schon ein paar.
Doch, es... Äh, Floxy, ich hab sogar gelesen,
dass manche Mainboards für diese Plattform
schon lieferbar sind, CPUs hingegen
nicht.
Äh, könntest du ein gutes Netzteil empfehlen?
500 Watt, was definitiv genug Anschlüsse hat.
Ja, also was ich... Ich bin ja ein...
Auch wenn ich noch hier ein BeQuiet!
Netzteil hab, mit dem man übrigens auch nix falsch machen kann.
Kann wirklich nix falsch machen.
Was ich gerne hab, ist, äh, an Netzteilen
ist... Sind die hier?
Obwohl die relativ teuer sind.
Äh, sind die?
Die Seite, ey.
Wozu? Ganz ehrlich,
wer hat diese Seite designt?
Wenn ich auf die Seite gehe, will ich mir die Details
von den Netzteilen angucken und nicht hier
Power, Performance, Prime,
Introduction Features und irgendwie
so ein komisches Ding. Ich will die Netzteile sehen.
Dazu muss ich natürlich erst runterscrollen, ja.
Ähm...
Ja, such dir hiervon eins aus.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt das Fanless.
Gibt's das eigentlich mittlerweile schon?
Das wollte ich mir vor einer Weile mal kaufen.
Gibt's das eigentlich mittlerweile schon? Natürlich nicht.
Gibt's wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht.
Nee, die Lieferbarkeit von den Dingern
ist manchmal... Nimm dir eins hiervon.
Das ist mit so die besten Netzteile, die du findest.
Meiner Ansicht nach. Gibt aber auch noch genug
andere gute Hersteller, aber ich mag, äh,
mag Seasonic.
Cooper, ist das das Netzteil der Höllenmaschine?
Das wusste ich nicht.
Aber es gibt noch gute andere Netzteile.
Was ist das für ein Lied?
Ähm...
Da.
What I Want, Offenbach und...
Offenbach.
Und Karl K.
Wer auch immer das ist.
Okay, machen wir mal wieder auf hier.
Mal weiter gucken.
So, ähm, guck, ich film jetzt mal die Mainboard.
Angucken, was es, was es da so gibt.
Nur mal so grob drüber. Nicht jedes einzelne Mainboard
an sich, ne? Ähm...
Also, was ich, was ich gelesen hab,
was ich, was ich gesehen hab von MSI
ist das hier. Das werde ich mir nicht
kaufen, weil...
Erstens.
465 Euro
für nen Mainboard.
Da kostet das Mainboard mehr als mein Prozessor.
Nicht,
dass ich da prinzipiell was dagegen hätte.
Die Frage ist nur, was bekommt
man dafür?
Und ich sehe da für mich wenig Vorteile
drin. Ähm...
Das Mainboard an sich, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
finde ich auch nicht schön.
Übrigens, äh,
soll ich euch, soll ich euch mal was zeigen?
Bin ich hier mal... Ah, glaub ich bin hier
gar nicht bei Twitter eingeloggt.
Oh, ne.
Ich muss euch mal was zeigen.
Ich hab mal, ich hab mal ein bisschen gelästert
über... Von der Weile, schon eine ganze
Weile her.
Über, über MSI und...
Ja, ich hab ein bisschen über MSI...
Man sieht's jetzt leider nicht. Bisschen über
MSI gelöst, gelästert. Auf der anderen Seite bin ich
gebannt.
Also, die nehmen das sehr ernst,
wenn man über ihre, über ihre
Mainboard-Beleuchtung lästert.
Da muss man
aufpassen. Das darf man,
darf man nicht übertreiben. Da gibt's den Bannhammer.
Das hab ich auch noch nicht
geschafft, dass mich ein Handwerkersteller gebannt hat.
Aber...
Was soll ich machen?
Ich glaube, das war wegen diesem Tweet hier.
Ich weiß aber gar nicht, warum.
Guck mal.
Ich hab damals geschrieben, das war 2016.
Wobei, ich bin, glaube ich, schon länger gebannt.
Ich hab damals geschrieben,
mein Ernsthaft, blinkende und leuchtende Mainboards.
Warum? Äh, wozu? Ich mein...
Hallo?
Oh, da gab's ein bisschen Diskussion drunter, was auch immer.
Und danach war ich irgendwann gebannt bei MSI.
Naja. Ja, Vloxik, ich kann's
ja nicht prüfen, weil ich mich jetzt hier nicht live
auf Twitter einloggen will und wo man eventuell
mein Passwort sieht.
Aber...
Picks or didn't happen, ne?
So, also das Mainboard gibt's.
Das ist wohl so...
Das...
Wie nennt man das so? Premium-Modell
von MSI
mit dem Namen
Godlike Gaming. Und was ich auch
sehr schön finde, weil ich mein,
ich bin ja schon gebannt, also kann ich jetzt auch noch mal ein bisschen lästern.
Was ich auch sehr...
Ich hab übrigens MSI bei dem Mainboard.
Was ich auch geil finde, ist...
Man sieht's hier gar nicht so schön.
Was da alles noch draufsteht, ist auch geil.
Maps, genau. Maps.
Ich will... Hier. Wo ist MSI?
Das ist, ey, Godlike Gaming.
Äh...
Da ist es. So, so wusste ich gar nicht,
dass die da sind.
Ähm, Bilder.
Aber das sind ja nicht noch
irgendwo in groß.
Auf der MSI-Seite gibt's das. Ja, da gibt's
das in groß.
Game here.
Genau. Ähm...
Da sieht man hier
Godlike Gaming
Enthusiast Unlimited
und was mir Angst macht, ja,
als, äh, sehr
Audio, äh,
begeisterter... Moment, mein...
WTF. Äh, mein Headset ist
auf der einen Seite aus. Ich muss das grad mal entknoten.
Ich bin sofort wieder da.
So, passt.
Ähm...
Was mir so als Audio-begeisterter Mensch
Angst macht, ist das hier.
Das macht mir echt Angst auf
Mainboards, sowas.
Extreme Audio Duck.
Da träum ich nachts von, von sowas.
Was ich an dem Mainboard gut finde, optischer Ausgang.
Okay, ähm...
Also, das werde ich mir nicht kaufen. Das ist mir viel zu teuer.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt... Also,
man muss sagen, von den Features her
ist das Mainboard schon geil, wenn man
es braucht. Man schaut sich hier
zum Beispiel mal an, dass da
irgendwie drei Netzwerkkarten drauf sind
mit einem eingebauten Switch,
dass man quasi seinen Nachbarrechner und Notebook
auch noch mitversorgen kann. Hey,
ey, wenn man es braucht, okay, meinetwegen.
Die Sache ist bloß, ich kann mir auch
einen 15-Euro-TP-Link-Switch mit 8 Ports
kaufen, da brauche ich kein 400-Euro-Mainboard.
Aber die haben sich ja bestimmt
schon was beigedacht. Also, das ist mir zu viel.
Das ist mir wirklich zu viel des Guten.
Kann man das einfach... Kann man das mal nach
Preis sortieren? Geht das irgendwie?
Wie sortiert man das nach Preis?
Ah. Okay, also
das Günstigste ist anscheinend das hier.
S-Rock...
S-Rock hab ich in meinem
Server, lustigerweise.
Allerdings dort die
Enterprise-Serie.
Es gibt von S-Rock tatsächlich
eine Server-Serie von Mainboards.
Nennt sich S-Rock Rack.
Ähm, aber
ich bin kein allzu großer
S-Rock-Fan, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Ähm,
Martin, wenn du so
auf Sound stehst, warum dann
keine Soundkarte? Oder hab ich was übersehen?
Äh,
weil ich ein Audio-Interface hab.
Ziemlich nice das Audio-Interface.
Was wahrscheinlich
Sound-Technisch so ziemlich alles,
was du dir an Gaming-Soundkarten
kaufen kannst, in die Tasche steckt.
Hier hat man ein ganz schönes Bild von.
Genau.
Deswegen brauch ich auch einen optischen Ausgang.
Ganz einfach.
Weil das, weil das per optisch, weil das halt
über Tossling angeschlossen wird.
Und das ist echt geil, das Ding.
Das hat sich gelohnt zu kaufen.
Ähm,
weil mich manche,
ähm, ähm,
die F...
eigentlich einige nach dem
Setup hier gefragt haben mit, mit, äh,
äh, Konsolen, PCs und so, ähm,
also mal ganz kurz, ich hab, ich hab das so geregelt.
Ich hab, äh, Kopf, also ich hab den, den, den Spielerechner hier dran
angeschlossen, über optischen Eingang.
Mein, äh, zweiten, zweiten Rechner hier nebendran,
den ich halt nebenbei verwende für, sei es jetzt hier Settings im Stream
vornehmen und sowas, während ich hier streame, ähm, über USB
angeschlossen. Das heißt, über den kann ich auch das Audio-Interface konfigurieren und so
was. Äh, vorne ist hier mein, mein Kopfhörer dran, oder meine beiden Kopfhörer.
Der MM, das, das MMX 300 Headset und, ähm, billiger Creative Kopfhörer.
Und hier an die anderen Anschlüsse, die noch an dieses Audio, die, die es hier noch gibt, an diesem Audio-Interface, ähm,
da hab ich alles andere dran.
Da hab ich, äh, die Konsolen dran angeschlossen und, ähm, die Mikrofone dran angeschlossen, noch
einen kleinen Mixer für, ähm, jetzt hier das, das, das Headset-Mikro und für weitere Inputs.
Da kann ich beispielsweise, könnte ich mein iPhone noch dran anschließen und sowas in der Richtung.
Und das kann ich dann hiermit alles schön zusammen mischen und aufs Ohr.
Das ist wirklich sehr praktisch.
Neben dem, dass die Quali natürlich auch super ist.
Ähm, verbessert eine Soundkarte den Sound von einem Headset oder von Kopfhörern?
Ähm, nee, aber sie kann sie verschlechtern.
Weißt du, wie ich das meine?
Also, ähm, also wenn du einen guten Kopfhörer hast, der, der wird nicht besser quasi durch, durch, durch den,
der kann nicht auf einmal mehr als das, was er eh kann.
Aber, ähm, wenn du jetzt eine Soundkarte anschließt oder irgendwie einen, ja, eigentlich kommt es ja auf den, äh, auf den
Digital-Analog-Konverter an und, ähm, da kann es schon sein, dass das halt kacke klingt, je nachdem.
Und das ist natürlich auch wichtig, dass du gutes Material hast.
Also, wenn du jetzt da mit irgendwelchen 128 MP3s oder so ankommst, ähm, AimFreaks, wieso, was hast du nicht verstanden an dem Video über Headsets?
Die meisten Gaming-Headsets, es gibt mittlerweile ein paar ganz brauchbare Gaming-Headsets, aber die meisten Gaming-Headsets, die sind ziemlich, ziemlich sinnlos und überteuert.
Also, Preis-Leistung sind die meisten Gaming-Headsets nicht der Wahnsinn.
So, aber jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Mainboards weiter an.
So, das sieht natürlich scheiße aus im Vergleich zu dem Super-Headsets.
mit sfp plus netzwerkkarte rein ich muss mal kurz nebenbei noch was futtern ich bin jetzt quasi von
der arbeit gekommen ausgestiegen aus dem zug auf direkt stream angemacht da ist unten drunter
medikator tp china router das ist weggeklickt aber hat genug anschlüsse den das hatte bloß
zweimal pizzi ich stand doch da moment moment die machen es aber auch immer schwer muss ich
sagen so was hatten wir ausgewählt die dinge warum kann es nicht eigentlich noch mehr kompären was
soll das denn dann gruppieren wir danach die anderen preis steht hier preis preis gibt es
nicht okay das moment wo ist es denn jetzt wo ist es denn eben hin von dem was eben ausgewählt habe
und
kann es sein dass die seite nicht immer gleich sortiert egal nochmal zack zack zack zack ja ja
ich habe in der zweiten reihe von rechts angefangen beim ersten mal na gut fangen wir
jetzt von links an das ist auch irgendwie intuitiver also auf jeden fall genug auf
jeden fall auch genug sata anschlüsse m2 slots ist nice to have nicht dass ich sie brauchen würde
usb ports reicht mir auch usb 3 1 reicht mir auch die mainboards mit grafik ausgaben grafik
ausgängen ich vermute mal das ist einfach nur verlängerung für die cpu grafikkarte oder weiß
dass jemand so war das zumindest früher also das wird voll und ganz ausreichend optical spd
gut also eigentlich reicht er fast jedes mainboard warum soll ich mir denn jetzt so ein super super
high end stinks extreme gaming oder doch immer dann nehmen wir jetzt da gucken wir jetzt einfach
mal bei geiz halt das billigste von msi was es gibt was nicht total aus sieht das sieht
aus das will ich nicht also das sieht das sieht das sieht richtig aus
und das hier das ist das ist zum beispiel
das billigste so das hat zweimal pcx das wäre okay also müssen wir irgendwie sagen wir mal
so 150 euro fürs mainboard wieso nur msi weil ich das erstmal nur noch einmal sie sortiert
habe danach gucken uns die anderen sachen an es sind doch 3 1 2 3 4 5 6 das reicht
ich brauche ich brauche ja keine 33 große vor einfach drei hat kein torchlink doch warum ist
das so scheiße warum stimmt das nicht ist ich sehe hier kein tors linker optischen zumindest
ich sehe nicht es hat das hat kein das hat kein dann fällt es schon mal flach so nächste
tomahawk der hat ein trotz liegt buxen das ist das wird das von anschließend ja doch schon
mal ganz gut drei pc express 33 links wie ist das richtige dafür pc express ist alle wie heißen die
langen pci 16 8 zumindest hat das auf jeden fall genug genug steckplätze und sieht nicht ganz so
beschissen aus also das könnte ich mir nicht vorstellen aber ich glaube das ist ein bisschen
satt dass man sich schon mal kaufen das hat eine ordentlich das hat einen optischen ausgang das
ist das wichtigste hat wie viel usb hat das pc hat da das usb 10 er er hat usb da kannst du kannst
kannst kannst ein salat draus machen so viel usb hast du hier das also ganz ehrlich dass das
wird mir reichen ja irgendwelches super overclocking geschicksal da kann ich ja accounts hier system
Wichten brauche ich eh nicht.
Also das könnte man schon mal ins nähere Auge fassen.
Wichtig, ganz wichtig.
Beleuchtung RGB, ganz wichtig.
So, was haben sie sonst?
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum braucht MSI, warum brauchen die 10 Mainboards?
Guck mal.
Und die meisten Mainboards liegen gerade mal 45...
Na, sagen wir mal so.
Die meisten Mainboards liegen 50 Euro auseinander im Preis.
Warum machen die nicht einfach drei?
Quasi ein Einsteigermodell, ein mittleres und ein Highend-Modell.
Sibaro, das ist eine gute Idee.
Nummer von dem Ding, notieren.
Was zahlt er?
So, was haben wir als nächstes?
SLI Plus.
SLI.
SLI habe ich kein...
SLI brauche ich nicht.
Ach, die Dinger sind für Grafikkarten oder was?
Und das hier nicht.
Warum?
Das muss mir mal einer erklären.
Warum sind die hier für Grafikkarten und das nicht?
Das passt doch auch.
Also ich habe aber keine...
Ich brauche kein SLI.
Keine...
Keine Ambitionen.
MSI Crate Gaming.
Oder...
Crate.
MSI Crate Gaming.
Verstärkt für...
Hohes Gewicht.
Aha.
Weil die Lanes an der CPU hängen.
Ja, wo sollen die Lanes denn sonst hängen, wenn nicht an der CPU?
Haben alle 16 Pins.
Ihr solltet der hier doch auch haben.
Ach so.
Der untere sieht nur aus, dass es quasi ordentlich hält.
Und es ist nur vielfach.
Aha.
Ne, guckt doch mal.
3x PCI-16.
Ah, Moment.
Einmal 16, einmal 8.
Man kann die Leute aber auch echt verwirren.
Ich meine...
Das ist ja schön und gut.
Also wahrscheinlich wollen sie uns hiermit sagen, es gibt 3x PCI-16-fach-Stecker.
Also, ähm, Buchsen, wo 16-fach-Geräte reinpassen.
Aber angebunden sind die nur mit 16, 8 und 4.
Oder wie?
Also sprich...
16, 8, 4.
Ne.
16, doch.
16, 8, 4.
Warum nennen sie das dann 16?
Warum nennen sie das nicht einfach einmal 16, einmal 8, einmal 4?
Hm.
Würde mir aber auch reichen, ehrlich gesagt.
Da kommt eine Grafikkarte rein.
Äh, hier unten kommt die Capture-Karte rein.
Da kommt die Netzwerke...
Also, ich weiß nicht, egal wie rum.
Bandbreite reicht eh dicke.
So, das vergleichen wir jetzt nochmal auf der MSI-Seite.
Oder gucken wir erstmal...
Gucken wir erstmal das Andere an.
Also, das, das würde mir aber auch reichen, ich mein...
Sind zwar nur 10 Euro, aber warum sollte ich mehr ausgeben?
Ja, und das hier hat...
Ah, okay, das hier hat sech...
Das hat 16, 4 und 1.
Okay.
Okay, verstehe.
Jetzt...
Okay.
Wir kommen der Sache näher.
Also, das wäre auch noch ne Option.
Auch wenn MSI mich gebannt hat.
Gaming Pro Carbon.
Das kann der dann jetzt besser.
Der sieht, der sieht fancy aus.
Das, das macht...
Das macht wahrscheinlich schon mal die 15 Euro Aufpreis aus.
Das leuchtet.
Cup of Pride.
Das leuchtet wirklich so, ne?
Okay, das hat auch 16, 8...
16, 8, 4.
Optischer Dossling.
So muss das sein.
Diesen tollen Error-Indicator, auf den sie jetzt herrscht.
Okay, das hat auch 16, 8, 4.
Optischer Dossling. So muss das sein.
Ist echt ganz praktisch.
Es ist echt ganz praktisch.
Ja?
Also, ich flay mir immer ganz gern mal alles so, was es so gibt.
Aber diese Anzeigen mit Fehlern sind wirklich ganz praktisch.
Was ich auch gut finde, sind Anschalter auf dem Mainboard.
Nicht unbedingt Must-have, aber ich finde Resetschalter und Anschalter auf dem Mainboard auch ganz praktisch.
Aber ich finde Resetschalter und Anschalter auf dem Mainboard auch ganz praktisch.
Was ist da jetzt der große Unterschied dazwischen?
Zwischen dem und dem anderen?
Der hat wahrscheinlich noch ein bisserl mehr USB.
Die vergleichen wir.
Die vergleichen wir gleich mal.
fünf raus, die fünf billigsten, die passen
und dann vergleichen wir die mal auf der MSI-Seite.
Okay.
Also gibt es ja im Prinzip
nur noch die zwei.
So, dann haben wir noch das
Gaming M5. Das hat das gleiche
Pinsel. Oh, das sieht schon
viel, viel, viel
stylischer aus, ja.
Und hat auch hier schon die ersten
bunten Sachen dran.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
was sich an den Mainboards hauptsächlich
ändert, ist, dass
das, was noch oben drauf gesteckt ist,
na, E-Achse sollte
eigentlich nicht passieren.
Oh, ach, guck mal hier,
der Nilsson,
der Beste.
Okay, ha!
Da können wir vergleichen. Das fällt
eh schon mal raus, weil
zu teuer. Was mich
aber interessieren würde, was an dem jetzt so
geil ist, außer dass es halt Netzwerkkarten
und so hat, drei Stück.
Okay, ähm,
das hat vier PCI-Express.
Einmal sechzehn, einmal acht,
zweimal vier.
Okay, das hat noch mehr,
noch mehr M2-Slots, brauche ich
eh nicht.
Mal ernsthaft, jemand, der nicht, der nicht
so technik-affin ist, das ist doch,
das müssen doch absolut
böhmische Dörfer sein, oder?
Das könnte schon fast als Verschlüsselung
durchgehen hier.
Wenn mir einer das hier schicken würde,
ne, nur diesen Abschnitt,
dann würde ich ihn fragen, ja, mit was hast
du das verschlüsselt?
Gebt mal Passwort.
Ähm,
das braucht, das ist, das ist okay,
ja, das ist aber nix, wo ich sagen würde, jawoll,
lass einfach mal 465 Euro für Mainboard ausgeben.
Äh, Mann,
das geht, du kannst, ähm,
kannst beim Windows-Installer
sagen, du willst reparieren.
Aber besser ist,
du sicherst den Kram vorher.
So.
Dann haben wir noch ein
E-Key.
Was ist denn ein E-Key?
Werbung.
Geh weg.
Ich dachte, das ist irgendwie ne, ne,
Pin-Belege oder so bei M2.
Ach so, ach,
das ist für, für, für Wireless-Karten.
Okay, aha.
Na gut, brauch ich alles nicht.
Bluetooth brauch ich auch nicht.
Für was brauch ich Bluetooth?
Wenn ich Bluetooth unbedingt brauch, kann ich mir auch einen Bluetooth-Stecker an
USB machen.
Das, das ist schnickstett,
das brauch ich alles nicht.
So, USB
3, C3,
ganz viele Dreier, ähm,
Killer-Netzwerkkarte brauch ich auch nicht.
Will ich gar nicht.
Ich will mal ne 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte verwenden.
Einmal TOS-Link, einmal, oh, PS2,
ganz wichtig.
RGB, also, das,
ich, ich, also, ich kann verstehen, dass,
das halt das, das Flagship ist, aber
wirklich brauchen tut man das nicht.
So, also konzentrieren wir uns mal eher auf die,
auf die, die hier.
Also, die zwei fliegen schon mal komplett raus.
Das, weil's einfach potthässlich aussieht.
Und ich glaub, das, weil's nicht genug Slots hat, oder irgendwie sowas.
So, weil das kleinste Mainboard, was wir uns rausgesucht haben, war das Tomahawk.
Bei dem hier, bei dem hier gab's keinen optischen Ausgang.
Steht hier eigentlich dabei, dass es optisch hat?
Nee, steht eh dabei.
Das hier hatte, genau, das sieht hässlich aus,
und die hatten, glaub ich, keinen optischen, keinen optischen Ausgang.
Das heißt, das kleinstmögliche ist das hier.
Gaming Plus ist identisch, mit dem ersten war er nur in Rot gefärbt.
Perfekt.
Tatsächlich, guck mal, das ist genau das gleiche.
Bloß Rot.
Geil.
Wichtig. Also, das kleinste mögliche ist das hier.
SLI Plus ist,
weil du, weil der hier noch mit, mit
mehr Lanes angebunden ist,
weil du hier 16 8-fach hast,
hier hast du plus 16, 16 und 4.
Okay.
Also, die Ausstattung hier, würde ich sagen,
ist exakt gleich.
Aber wirklich auf, auf den Buchstaben gleich.
Nicht nur hier, die, die alle, oder.
Die haben alle exakt die gleiche Ausstattung
Die haben alle exakt die gleiche Ausstattung.
Wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe.
Die haben alle exakt
genau das Gleiche.
Das heißt, da kann es
kein Unterschiede geben.
Kein Unterschiede geben.
Oder was ist, was ist der Unterschied zwischen denen hier oben
Ja, die Anschlüsse, das sehe ich.
Das sehe ich, aber hier, bei den Erweiterungsslots, ist
Kein Unterschied.
okay das heißt okay da ist es aber so die sind die gleichen hier dass da ist
halt nur vierfach also dass sie sind die gleichen im endeffekt
grob drüber scannen hier ja okay also die die gehen alle die die gehen alle
hier die und das fällt raus weil es einfach zu teuer ist so anschlüsse haben
wir hier gut dvd das ist mir kein displayport ich habe mich habe meine
grafiker da drin also ich schließe nix an das wird grün hinterlegt wenn die
identen ich sehe hier nichts grün hinterlegt das
ach so wenn du drüber gehst cool cool also die seite ist echt gut dass das ist
echt gut die seite es gefällt mir das gefällt
und
okay das heißt aha dass die die seite ist echt gut zum vergleichen gut hier
ist der unterschied die haben displayport und die hier hat der hat
schon killer netzwerkkarte und das ac ist quasi das karbon mit wifi oder
hätte ich jetzt mal so vom namen gedacht haben so der unterschied ist der
ist der unterschied die seite ist echt gut zum vergleichen gut hier ist der
vielleicht muss ich diesem
scheiße
allerdings nicht immer alles gleich
ganze linie falsch auf das ist个
goss turned-tian
mal brinne oder auch noch mal hintenanschlüsse also oder oder
das istRockcast tug and loadiiiiii
esar oberthodeice
zwei netzwerken 222 soundkarten zwei soundkarten
ok warum nicht dann halt zwei grad dann halt zwei soundkarten sind die
grafikkartenpreise von bitcoin mining immer noch so hoch das letzte mal wo ich
geguckt habe war das also war der fall aber nicht bei allen grafikkarten ja
140 leute schauen sich wenn wir uns anders also im ganz ehrlich dass das
kleinste reicht so dass das reicht das hier ich will kein sli machen ich bin
absolut kein sli fern das reicht okay der andere seite man
kann aber die andere seite die fünf die fünf euro die das jetzt ausmacht das ist
auch nicht so wild oder ja also im prinzip
ja also im prinzip
eins hiervon im prinzip eins hier von so große mal schnell was die anderen
hersteller haben guck mal also ist rek Red...
kein bock nielsche kann man kann ich jetzt quasi du hast du eben eingerichtet
kann ich jetzt hier quasi verkleidet doch jetzt noch vergleich da ich will
die einfach alle aus und aber vergleich
dann gucken wir uns erstmal die billigen an sich wahrscheinlich ähnlich
Ich will, weil da irgendwas fehlt.
Wisst ihr, schon mal keinen optischen Ausgang.
Schon mal keinen optischen Ausgang.
Optischer Ausgang.
Passt doch, passt doch.
Können wir die zwei nämlich weg machen.
Die zweite bei.
Gut.
Also schauen wir mal an, was Asus jetzt hier zu bieten hat.
Finde nur ich das so kryptisch.
Also so generell die Auswahl bei Mainboards.
Das ist so ganz viele verschiedene Produkte mit minimalen Unterschieden.
Und immerhin so 5 Euro im Preis auseinander.
Können die Hersteller nicht einfach machen.
Irgendwie Billigprodukt.
Dann so, sagen wir mal so Einsteiger.
Mittel und Highend.
Das wird doch reichen.
Du brauchst doch hier keine 14 Mainboards oder sowas.
Mini-ITX.
Äh.
Ähm.
Also hier ist, hier ist Wifi und Gedulds dabei.
Das ist Overkill, das brauch ich nicht.
Netzwerkkabel beste.
So, was ist?
Einmal 16, einmal 8, einmal 2.
Okay.
Und das sieht wenigstens auch schon.
Bei Asus sieht wenigstens auch das Einsteiger-Mainboard nicht so hässlich aus.
Also das.
Das wird es auch tun.
Einmal.
Wie viel USB haben wir?
2x31, 4x30.
2x2.
Toslink optisch.
Hoffe ich mal.
Ich hoffe die haben alle Toslink optisch.
Steht ja nicht dabei.
Ah, die sollten alle Toslink optisch haben.
Ja.
Naja.
Jetzt bereich ich mir da auch das Billigste.
Kann die Mainboards oben wegklicken?
Wo?
Da?
Hä.
Wo kann man die wegklicken?
Ne, ich wollte es ja hier aus der Auswahl entfernen.
Aber.
So wie ich das sehe, kann ich auch bei Asus fast das günstigste nehmen.
So überhaupt kein Ding.
Also bei Asus kommen auch, also das hier ist, das ist wieder Overkill, das brauche ich nicht.
Also ich muss ehrlich sagen, Mainboards, es geht eigentlich fast alles bis auf die Billigsten.
So, dann gucken wir als letztes jetzt nochmal uns die Mainboards an von.
Gucken wir uns als letztes nochmal die Mainboards an von.
Komm, wir schauen auch nochmal ASRock, was die so haben.
Das geht, ich finde das geht optisch, das sieht nicht ganz so draufgekackt aus wie das von MSI.
Aber kein optisches, kein optischer Toslink, das ist auch Schlusskriterium, schau mal.
Direkt in die Tonne.
Kein optischer.
Wifi.
Würde ich sagen.
Ja.
Für Antennen.
Optischer Toslink, das erste hier.
Auch, auch mit, mit, mit Wifi.
Why not?
Also anscheinend sollte man sich ASRock auch mal angucken.
ASRock Fidelity.
Gibt es den überhaupt noch?
Ich glaube der, ich glaube der spielt jetzt.
Der spielt jetzt Pupke, ne?
Habe ich gesehen hier.
Der Fatality.
Pupke Owner ist es geworden.
War eine Frage an den Nilzorn, was würdest du nehmen?
Ähm.
Kein optischer Toslink.
Na bei, bei Gigabyte ist das ja gerade einfach.
Äh.
Noch nicht mal Bilder.
Optischer Toslink.
Okay.
Ja.
Beispielmäßig.
Prinzip gibt es noch nie zu vergleichen.
Gigabyte scheint so ziemlich Anti-Toslink zu sein.
Nee ich mein Nilzorn von den ganzen Mainboards so insgesamt, ..
hättest du da einen Favorit so unabhängig von welcher Marke?
Falls du dir die schon mal angeguckt hast.
Okay.
Mal ganz kurz mal angucken was MSI so am Start hat .
Äh, Gigabyte so am Start hat.
Was ist hier der Unterschied?
1 x 8.
1 x 4.
. Ne.
2 mal gigabit das brauche ich nicht auch wieder killer networks dass das scheint
bei den high end boards so dass der verkaufs verkaufsschlag einmal
thunderbolt das 144 von msi das war das jahre als das great gaming oder das
tomahawk hast du meines also im prinzip die gehen auch fast alle
also ganz ehrlich mainboard ist diesmal muss mir in der ruhigen minute noch mal
angucken aber das kann man bis auf die einsteiger mainboards eigentlich das
einsteiger das zeug ist immer noch doppelt bis dreifach so teuer wie
normalerweise also bis auf die günstigsten der serie kann man das
eigentlich fast alles kaufen mainboards ist detail frage mittlerweile
ok gut ich meine was braucht man da als letztes noch also wir wissen dass auf
jeden fall
ein
ich guck jetzt mal welches msi mainboard der nilsson meint das tomahawk das fand ich
sah auch gut aus das fand ich das war eine gute konkurrenz das ist schön billig also
immer noch dreimal teurer als alle mainboards aber es ist relativ günstig hat alles dabei
was man braucht also wahrscheinlich wird es das hier haben wir noch mal ein fragezeichen
dahinter sind wir bei 150 schreiben wir einfach mal hin
ok
Ist zur Zeit relativ teuer, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe.
Wie viele RAM-Stecker hat denn das Ding?
Vier Stück.
Ach, kein Ding.
Ja, Naruno Katze, ich verwende den Onboard-Sound nicht.
Also, ich verwende den On...
Das, was auf Sound auf dem Mainboard drauf ist, verwende ich rein per optischem Kabel an mein Audio-Interface.
Ich verwende nichts von dem, was das kann.
Ich habe an dem Mainboard von meinem aktuellen Gaming-Rechner, außer dem optischen Anschluss, ist noch nicht eine Audio-Buchse verwendet worden.
So, was kann es denn für RAM?
Gibt es... Hey, gibt es ein Mainboard, was...
Jetzt war mal so richtig budget.
Gibt es ein Mainboard, was DDR3 kann?
Nee, oder?
Nee, wird es nicht geben.
Könntest du nämlich mal den alten RAM weiterverwenden.
Die Geschwindigkeitsunterschied macht es wahrscheinlich.
Ich bin eigentlich eh nicht fett.
Und, das hier ist es.
So, was will der RAM?
Viermal DDR4.
Gucken wir mal RAM.
Gut, ich meine, langsamer wird der natürlich auch gehen.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen, mal angenommen, zwischen 4 GHz, also preislich, muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Der Unterschied zwischen 4 GHz, sagen wir mal, und...
Ahnung, 2006.
Oh, warum muss ich denn jetzt diesen, äh?
Dem hier.
Ah, Moment.
Preise pro Gigabyte, 38.
Ähm, das macht keinen Unterschied.
Oh, nee, Moment.
Ich bin...
am falschen.
Oh, das macht unter...
Das ist schon ein Unterschied.
Wollte gerade sagen, weil ich brauche gar keinen RAM, damit der so viel Wumms hat.
Oh, Moment.
Die mit dem Mainboard wollten wir bloß sagen, man kann maximal.
Ja, da sind wir doch schon in...
günstigeren Gefilden.
Äh, Lord Andy Mion lohnt sich so viel Giga, also überhaupt, nee.
Generell.
Also, die...
Also, mehr RAM.
Also, RAM übertakten oder beziehungsweise...
da irgendwie, ähm, besonders hochgezüchteten RAM kaufen, so.
Das lohnt sich selten.
Das lohnt sich wirklich ganz selten.
Früher hattest du das Problem, dass wenn du quasi übertaktet hast, du ein gesamtes System
übertaktet hast, also sprich nicht nur den CPU-Takt, dann musstest du manchmal schnelleren
RAM kaufen, dass das funktioniert oder du musstest zumindest den Teiler runterstellen fürs RAM.
Das ist, dass dir dein PC nicht abkackt.
Aber soweit.
Ich weiß, ich hab schon lange nichts mehr übertaktet.
Ich bin immer klargekommen, die letzten paar Generationen, ach, da muss ich recht, da waren
halt auch immer ziemlich gut.
Mit der Standard-Config.
Aber mittlerweile kannst du, glaube ich, CPU-Takt so alles so einstellen.
G-Skill.
Rip Jaws.
Boah, das klingt ja schon wieder...
Oh, das ist wieder so ein RAM, der gegen meinen CPU-Lüfter stößt.
CPU-Lüfter müssen wir auch gleich nochmal was gucken.
Wobei, wir haben ja schon geklärt, mein alter CPU-Lüfter passt eigentlich.
Vielleicht kaufe ich mir auch einen neuen CPU-Lüfter.
Guck mal, wir haben jetzt...
Wir haben noch so...
Wir haben so wenig, in Anführungsstrichen, ausgegeben.
Wir sind jetzt gerade noch bei 550 Euro.
Da kommt jetzt nochmal RAM dabei für...
Weiß ich.
So.
Warum dann Z370, wenn du nicht OC machst?
Ja, was denn sonst?
Das gibt ja sonst nix.
Gibt ja sonst für die neuen Intel-CPUs nix.
So, da kommt jetzt 2x8 rein und gut ist.
So.
Crucial Ballistics Elite.
Das sind zwei Stück, ne?
2x8.
Ach ja.
Easy.
Also sagen wir mal, 150 Euro kostet das RAM nochmal obendruf.
150...
Also RAM kostet nochmal 150 Euro.
Da ist eigentlich fast egal, was ich hier nehme.
Hier...
Die Dinger sind, glaube ich, relativ...
Sind die relativ flach?
Näh.
Beim letzten Rechner hatte ich mir auch so Cousin-Dinger gekauft.
Da habe ich dann den Kühler abgemacht, dass es noch an den CPU-Lüfter gepasst hat.
Also RAM, der einfach noch aussieht wie RAM-Riegel, gibt es anscheinend nicht mehr, oder?
Es ist ja nicht so, dass der Scheiß was bringen würde.
Weil ich meine, was bringt dem RAM-Riegel das?
Als hätte der davon jetzt irgendwas.
Alles krasse Namen, krass gestylt.
Also ein einfacher RAM-Riegel, das gibt es nicht mehr.
Naja.
Also 150 Euro für RAM.
Dann nehme ich einfach den, der lieferbar ist und am billigsten in dem Shop.
Kauf doch RGB-RAM.
Gibt es RAM mit RGB-Beleuchtung?
Das muss ich jetzt mal ran gucken.
Ach du Scheiße.
Das gibt es ja wirklich.
Wobei, hey, ich muss sagen.
Ich muss sagen.
Also, ich finde das...
Ich finde das harmonischer irgendwie und hübscher, als der Weihnachtsbaum auf dem Mainboard.
Das würde ich sogar benutzen.
Kostet halt einfach mal 80 Euro mehr als der andere RAM.
Aber ich meine RGB-Beleuchtung, ja?
Du hast RGB-RAM...
Hast du den selbst gekauft oder ist der Rechner gesponsert?
Disclaimer please.
Äh...
Nicht Disclaimer.
Disclosure.
Also, nee.
Kein RGB-RAM.
War ein Sponsor-PC.
Na dann, wenn es ein Sponsor-PC ist, dann pappen die ja immer.
Umso abgespaceter, umso besser.
Ja, wir machen hier irgendwie Crucial Ballistix, Elite Dim...
Nee, äh...
8.
Wo ist es hier? 8.
Ah, hier, den machen wir rein.
Das ist eigentlich vollkommen wurscht.
Zwei Stück.
Oder die hier, zwei Stück.
RAM kostet 150.
Weiß ich...
Ich werd den RAM reinpacken, der in dem jeweiligen Shop verfügbar ist und am billigsten.
Zu dem Tag, wo ich bestelle.
So, im Prinzip reicht das.
So, jetzt gucken wir doch abschließend einmal wegen CPU-Lüfter.
Weil, ich hab mir gerade überlegt,
ich könnte mein jetziges Mainboard
einfach 1 zu 1 so rausbauen,
inklusive RAM und allem
und CPU-Lüfter
und baue es einfach in ein anderes Gehäuse ein
und löse meinen jetzigen zweiten Rechner
damit ab.
Wenn Lüfter, dann Noctua.
Ja, Noctua hat geile Lüfter, das stimmt.
Wirklich geile Lüfter.
Hab ich in meinem Server, Noctua-Lüfter.
Was haben die denn so?
D14 schreibt einer.
Sind teuer, oder?
An CPU-Lüfter spare ich nicht.
Es gibt so Sachen, wo ich mir mittlerweile abgewöhnt hab,
dran zu sparen.
Ich spare nicht mehr an Gehäuse,
ich spare nicht mehr an Netzteil
und ich spare nicht mehr an CPU-Lüfter.
Das sind die Sachen, wo es am einfachsten ist,
quasi zu sagen, ah, mal ein bisschen billiger,
aber da spare ich nicht mehr dran.
Ich bin auch mittlerweile
ziemlich empfindlich, wenn ich
meinen Rechner höre.
Also beim Spielen mit ZZ kein Problem,
aber
im Desktop-Betrieb
muss das
nahezu
silent sein.
Und Noctua ist gut.
Vor allem, ich hab noch nie
in meinem Leben so einen hochwertigen Lüfter
gesehen wie Noctua.
Also
auch die ganze
Packung, Aufmachung und was da an
Zubehörteilen
dabei ist, ja. Also von
Verlängerungskabel zum
Kabel irgendwie zum
Trosseln, dann diese
Gummifüßchen und sowas.
Also Noctua hat mich wirklich begeistert.
Was ist verklebt?
Achso.
Ja gut, das braune bei Noctua
sieht nicht wirklich hübsch aus, das stimmt schon.
Warum keine
Wasserkühlung?
Weil ich nicht übertakte und
Luft reicht und
ich immer noch kein Fan von
Wasser im Rechner bin
und ich nicht weiß, wo ich den Wärmetauscher hinstellen
soll und
weil ich nicht übertakten will
und Luft leise genug ist.
So,
NU14 ist top.
Der da?
Ne, NHU14S.
Was ist denn da der Unterschied?
Das Ding heißt sogar gleich.
Sieht aber anders aus.
Äh,
in the game, ich meine das Ding,
wo halt die Lüfter dran sind.
Achso.
Ja, aber wozu?
Wozu Wärmekühl? Das ist sogar teurer als
noch. Ok, die Lüfter sind
ordentlich, kostet bloß
ein bisschen.
Ah, das ist C14, das ist U14.
Ok.
Also da beiß ich vielleicht
nochmal in den sauren Apfel und hol mal noch den
als Lüfter dabei.
Naja, im Desktopbetrieb
sind die doch bestimmt alle leise.
Gehst du zur BlizzCon? Ne.
Ja, die Band kenn ich.
Ähm.
Wie viel?
Zu den Lüftern lese ich mir ein paar Tests durch.
Gucken wir doch mal, was es hier gibt.
PC Games Hardware.
Der beste Single Tower Kühler.
Na, wenn ich das schon lese, dann
mach ich das ja schon
gleich schaff hier auf den Lüfter.
Werbung.
In deinem F4 hörst du keinen
Oktur Lüfter. Ich höre auch in meinem Server
keinen Oktur Lüfter.
Guck dir auch mal den Be Quiet
Pure Rock an. Ok, guck ich
auch mal.
Welchen? Slim? Nicht slim?
Was ist das für eine Distribution?
Manjaro mit i3 WM.
Wenn dich interessiert, wie das eingerichtet ist,
kannst du dir das letzte Video angucken.
Tabaluga 1.1.0.
Weil da haben wir das zusammen eingerichtet.
Von
Anfang an mit Minimalinstallation
bis zu Desktop
mit allem, was du hier so siehst.
Äh, das Lineup ist
also, Intel hat das heute
quasi, heute ist wahrscheinlich die NDA gefallen
gehe ich mal von aus.
Und ich habe gelesen bei einigen Shops,
dass die CPUs
lieferbar sind, quasi so ab
19. oder 20. rum.
Vielleicht aber auch schneller.
Na gut, der kostet
aber auch nur die Hälfte.
Der Um... also wirklich
die Qualität von den Oktur Lüfter, die ist
wirklich geil. Die ist wirklich geil.
Die sehen zwar nicht
sonderlich hübsch aus, ja, aber
das ist wirklich 1A.
Kühlleistung. Um die Lautstärke
und bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
dort wird er störend.
Aha.
Einfache Montage finde ich immer gut.
Okay, was ist
NFA 15? Sind das Gehäuse Lüfter
von denen, oder wie?
Ja, anscheinend.
Das ist das Gehäuse Lüfter
von denen.
Brauch ich nicht.
Ah, den finde ich gut.
Lautstärke. Haben die
Lautstärke gemessen?
Drehzahl. Ah, hier Lautstärke.
Na gut, 35
höre ich schon. Wobei,
ob ich die aus dem Gehäuse... Na doch.
Wenn es hier mal im Arbeitszimmer
ruhig ist,
ich bin da recht...
Also, ich höre sowas immer ganz gut raus.
Das werde ich auch
aus dem geschlossenen Gehäuse hören.
Na, bei mir im Zimmer
ist definitiv keine 34 bis 39.
Garantiert nicht.
Ich habe ein Laut...
Ich lege jetzt mal ein Messgerät
ins Zimmer. Wartet mal kurz.
Ich lege das jetzt mal auf meinem Stuhl hier mitten ins Zimmer.
34.
34 mitten im Zimmer.
Also ungefähr
dann auch so den Abstand.
Aber ich habe gerade zwei Rechner an
und das komplette Equipment
hier sonst noch.
Und die Rechner höre ich auch.
Also 35 höre ich.
Aber das ist nicht so, dass es stören würde
großartig.
Aber ein bisschen leiser könnte das Ganze schon sein.
Naja.
Also, aber ich finde
den Noctua Lüfter...
Also, ich habe ja
hier ein paar im Einsatz und
die Qualität hat mich schon überzeugt.
Also vielleicht werde ich mir den auch noch
einholen in der Richtung.
Oder ich nehme den ein bisschen günstigeren.
Was hat eben noch jemand empfohlen?
Diesen Be Quiet da.
Ah, das hat an einem Forum...
Naja.
Ohne Messwerte bringt mir das nichts.
Dann haben wir noch den NH...
Was hatten wir hier noch?
Wie alt die Dinger schon sind, ne?
So.
Der ist lauter.
Nein, das ist Temperatur.
Lautstärke?
Was ist denn die Lautstärke?
Ah, Lautstärke.
Ja, okay.
So wirklich richtig
leise ist das nettes Ding.
Der Test ist von 2013.
Ich bin bei Reddit.
Ja, aber ich bin nicht angemeldet in Schleswig.
Aber Lüfter ist jetzt mal nicht so wichtig.
Also Lüfter rechnen wir noch mal.
Keine Ahnung.
40 Euro oder so.
Bam. Guckt mal.
Da sind wir immer noch recht günstig dabei.
Was haben wir hier?
400, 550,
äh, 600, 700,
750.
Für 750
in Kombination
mit meinen SSDs
und der 1080 Ti für einen wirklich
absolut High End System
ist doch als Upgrade in Ordnung.
Was?
Thermal Riot True Spirits.
Na, weniger als 30 dBA brauche ich
net.
Aber weniger als 36 wäre schon was.
Weniger als
30 brauche ich net. 30 höre ich net.
Aus dem Gehäuse schon mal gar net.
Ist halt so,
dass DB generell ne ziemlich
Kack-Einheit ist.
So wie die
halt skaliert, ne?
Nicht so, dass das quasi linear steigen würde.
Wenn ja, glaube ich,
ganz gut.
Ja, wie das, wie das, wie das steigt.
Also 36
ist in der ganzen Ecke lauter als 30.
Wenn das stimmt,
wenn das stimmt,
ist das mein Lüfter.
Das heißt nicht Soon, es heißt Sohne.
Nur mal so ein bisschen auf
wichtig, wichtig getan jetzt.
Ja, den, den finde ich
ganz nett.
Hardware Lux auch gute Seite.
Für sowas.
Danke für die
Korrektur.
Das ist gern geschehen.
Sowas korrigiere ich immer gern.
Ein bisschen wichtig tun muss ja auch manchmal sein.
Testresultat, Lautstärke.
Ähm, Iron Jesus.
Guck mal, was für Lüfter ich
aktuell habe.
Ist fast der gleiche.
Den nehme ich auch. Also den würde ich,
den würde ich einfach nehmen für den Neuen.
Aber ich finde die Idee jetzt langsam ganz gut,
dass ich das Alte einfach
eins zu eins so intakt lasse und ins andere
Gehäuse umbaue und mir
noch einen neuen Lüfter hole.
Thumbnail Riot True Spirit.
Guck.
Von Veja 21. Lull.
Äh, The Game von
was habt ihr es da gerade? Was ist mit 60 Euro
und von was kriegst du mit 60 Euro?
Meinst du jetzt, äh, redest du von
Lüfter oder von Mainboards,
die man sich kaufen sollte zum Übertakten oder?
Ja, Noctua Lüfter haben wir uns gerade
angeguckt. Noctua finde ich
ist ein super Hersteller. Ähm,
und zu dem tendiere
ich auch aktuell.
Lohnt es sich von einem 6.850K
aufzurüsten auf einen
8.700K? Ähm,
ich bin nicht so fit, was Intel CPU
Bezeichnung anbelangt, aber ich würde aus dem Bauch raus
sagen, nee.
Aber guck mal, was das Ding hat.
Nee.
Das lohnt sich nicht.
Ähm, sei denn du hast
zu viel Geld. Aber dann,
dann ist ja auch nicht die Frage, ob
es sich lohnt.
Also,
ich finde den Noctua Lüfter
trotzdem ganz gut. Egal.
Lüfter, das guck ich mir
dann an. Ich schau jetzt
eine Sache, gucken wir jetzt nochmal.
Ist denn irgendein Shop
schon so mutig und sagt, er ist lieferbar?
Das kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen.
Wir klicken uns den Kram gerade mal
beim Mine Factory zusammen.
Einmal den hier, please.
Kein Montageservice.
Ähm, dann haben wir noch
einen MSI Terminator
oder wie hieß das Ding?
Tomahawk.
RAM DDR4.
Irgendwie das Billigste halt. Sind das 16?
Sind das 16 GB?
Ah, perfekt.
Guck mal, da ist sogar
der Noctua Lüfter noch drin.
Wie hieß das Ding?
Oh! Warum ist der so teuer?
The fuck?
Warum ist der so teuer?
Will ich verarschen? Das kauf ich dir nicht.
Das kauf ich dir nicht.
Der kostet bei anderen Shops
kostet der 50 oder so.
Warum ist der so teuer?
Hä? Wart mal.
Wir haben noch vorhin geguckt,
da war der doch viel günstiger.
Äh, wat?
Wart mal. Kann das sein, dass
ich einfach auf das Falsche gerade gucke?
Der war doch
aber vorher auch billiger.
Der war doch aber vorher auch billiger.
Der hat irgendwie 53 gekostet oder so.
Ich mach nochmal die Tabs auf.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Der ist aber echt teuer.
Kann das sein, dass die den hier
nicht haben?
Die haben den hier einfach nicht.
Dann machen wir stellvertretend mal
den bisschen günstigeren rein.
Nur mal so, um zu gucken, was es am Ende
verkosten würde, der ganze Spaß.
Also sind wir bei 740 Euro.
Damit kann ich leben.
Da ist noch Luft nach
unten, weil
ich habe jetzt einfach das genommen, was hier
verfügbar ist. Also den Kühler kriegen wir auf jeden Fall
günstiger.
Und vielleicht auch ein anderer, weil das ist echt schon ganz
happig für einen Kühler.
Patrick, ich kann nicht in besserer Quali streamen,
weil ich nur 6 MBit upload habe.
Das liegt also nicht daran, dass
mit der Grafikkarte könnte ich da schon mehr machen.
Aber
mehr geht halt auf Twitch nicht.
So.
Das
ist doch schon mal ein ganz gutes Setup.
Das steht und fällt jetzt damit,
wann die
CPU lieferbar ist.
Ha?
Du siehst, dass ich bei Unity
Media bin. Woher siehst du das?
Wo siehst du das?
6 MBit ist mit CPU ja nicht so
viel anders. Ja, die GPU sieht ein bisschen schlechter aus.
Ähm.
Aber
das macht es jetzt anders aus. Ich meine,
das hier ist Standbild.
Ne, das ist gerade 1080.
So.
Na, vielleicht mache ich ja dann Software Encoding.
Wenn da genug
Wumms dabei ist. Warum nicht? Muss ich mal gucken.
Warum ich nicht die Nvidia Software
nehme, weil man mit der nicht so viele Sachen
einstellen kann, wie OBS.
Ob ich den 8700
übertakte, muss ich mal gucken.
Würde das mit dem Mainboard überhaupt gehen?
Warum keine AMD
CPU? Ja, ich war ja quasi kurz davor
mir eine AMD CPU zu kaufen.
Aber
Intel hat heute neue CPUs vorgestellt
und ich finde
die Kombination ist am besten.
Zur Zeit.
Vor allem, wenn man als hauptsächliche
Sache hat
spielen. Gefolgt
von dem hier. Aber das hier ist das wichtigste.
Da ist Intel gerade
wieder vorne.
Es hat sogar einen One-Click-Overclock.
Das ist doch auch nice.
Und wenn ich mir den dicken
Lüfter draufpappe,
dann bleibt das Ding auch
kühl genug.
Jetzt ne Runde BF. Ne, jetzt ne Runde
Abendessen. Ich habe jetzt
ne Mini-Ecke
Brot gefuttert gerade
während dem Streben, weil ich euch nicht vorschmatzen wollte.
Ich gehe jetzt erstmal was essen.
Reicht zum Zocken nicht auch an euer E5? Doch.
Mit Sicherheit.
Ja, über Wasserkühlung
habe ich auch nachgedacht, will ich nicht.
Bin ich, es ist nicht.
Bin ich kein Fan von.
Brauche ich auch nicht.
Also gibt's
Luftkühlung ist leise genug.
In dem Fall.
Also.
Und ist auch billiger.
Über den Aldi PC, ja. Angeblich hat
Aldi oder beziehungsweise Medion
schon PCs
im Regal stehen mit den neuen Intel CPUs.
Also Aldi
könnte mir ja mal ein 8700K
verkaufen.
750 Euro sind
nur Aufrüstkosten.
Oder sagen wir mal 700.
Eigentlich sind es 680, weil ich könnte meinen
alten CPU-Kühler ohne Probleme weiterverwenden.
Sag mal Patrick und
Nils, um was geht's bei euch gerade
mit 5 Gigahertz und Aufpreis
und sonst was? Könnt ihr mir das mal nochmal kurz
ähm
erklären?
So.
Aber, äh,
äh, Enderboy
ne, oder wer hat das gefragt?
Andiversum, das ist nur Aufrüstpreis.
Achso.
Ob 8700
oder 8700K.
Die Frage stellt sich für mich überhaupt nicht.
Ich kauf mir einfach das Beste.
Und, dass der K mit
offenem Multiplikator ist, hab ich auch keine Schmerzen mit.
Ist ja nicht verkehrt.
Also das Beste, was noch halbwegs sinnvoll
ist, ne. Bevor jetzt einer ankommt,
Max, warum kaufst du dir dann keine Titan als Grafikkarte
und sowas.
Aber ich find das okay.
700 Euro, quasi zum
Aufrüsten,
was aus nem
relativ alten PC, der aber immer noch nicht schlecht
ist, wieder
den krassesten High-End-Shit überhaupt
macht. Muss man ja auch mal sagen.
Natürlich kann man das immer noch übertrieben,
man kann sich irgendwie ne noch
teurere CPU kaufen,
man kann sich ne noch teurere Grafikkarte kaufen,
aber, ähm,
im Rahmen dessen, was
gerade noch sinnvoll ist,
ist das eigentlich das Beste, was du dir aktuell holen kannst.
Ja, das stimmt.
Für Gaming lohnt sich das nicht, Patrick.
Das ist wahr. Das braucht kein Mensch.
Wahrscheinlich ist dein Game
sogar langsamer.
Richtig. Das, was ich kauf, ist für Gaming
das Beste, was es gibt.
Ja, das mit RAM-Preisen stimmt noch, aber
ganz ehrlich,
die 80 Euro mehr im Vergleich
zu letztem Jahr oder vor zwei Jahren
verkrafte ich auch noch.
Wie viele Standard-Gehäuse-Lüfter hat das Fractal F4?
Ähm,
ich glaube, ich guck da mal rein,
ich hoffe, ich reiß jetzt hier nichts runter,
weil ich hab meinen Schreibtisch wieder hochgefahren.
Ich glaube, standardmäßig ist nur vorne einer
drin gewesen.
Ah, ich kann nicht aufmachen,
weil was vor der Tür steht. Äh, gucken wir mal.
Ich glaub, standardmäßig war vorne nur einer drin.
Jaja, Tommy, klar,
das reicht auch, Dicke.
Was? Ah, ne.
Two Silent Series R2-Fans
included. Okay, zwei Stück sind drin.
Ah,
ja klar, der hat ja hinten noch einen.
Ich hatte vergessen,
dass das Netzteil, das Netzteil ist ja unten, ne?
Jaja, genau.
Passt.
Aber ich würde mir das R5
kaufen, wenn ich mir ein neues kaufe.
Also quasi,
also quasi den da.
Wenn ich mir schon einen neuen kaufe.
Kann man sich,
weiß jemand, ob man sich von Geizhals
irgendwo eine Mail schicken lassen kann,
wenn
ein Produkt
bei einem Händler verfügbar wird?
Also sprich,
sobald irgendein Shop
den Prozessor auf verfügbar
setzt, kann man sich dann benachrichtigen lassen.
Programmier doch selbst, ja.
Also ich gehe mal
davon aus, das wird noch ein paar Tage dauern.
Vielleicht auch noch eher 1-2 Wochen, bis man das
ordentlich bekommt.
Also aktuell hat es keiner lieferbar.
Jetzt vorbestellen.
Was ist denn das?
Verfügbarkeit bestellt.
Achso, Sie haben das bestellt.
Ok.
Und sind da 10.
Jetzt vorbestellen.
Ja Patrick, das stimmt, das ist nicht schwierig.
Kann Mindfactory das nicht?
Doch, bestimmt.
Vielleicht hat es ja nicht Mindfactory als erstes gelistet,
sondern jemand anderes.
Was sind die PCs bei dir auf der Arbeit
eigentlich annehmbar? Du meinst, ob man damit
arbeiten kann? Ja.
Also wir haben nur noch
Notebooks.
Das machen wir doch jetzt einfach mal.
Das sind Notebooks
auf als erstes programmier ich keine 8 Stunden.
Ich gucke mir eher an, was andere Leute
programmiert haben.
Außerdem
sind das Notebooks mit Docking Station.
Kann man uns das da rausholen?
Wir können jetzt hier sagen, zack.
Ja, das ist halt nicht sehr einheitlich, wie die das
beschreiben. Jetzt vorbestellen,
bestellt, noch nicht bestellt.
Die Frage ist, ob dann,
gucken wir uns das bei einem anderen PC mal an,
ob da verfügbar dran steht.
Irgendwas, was halt verfügbar ist.
Lagernd. Lagernd.
Lagernd.
Sofortversand. Ja, der Text
ist halt nicht wirklich, wir könnten uns
aber die Hintergrundfarbe angucken.
Ne, wir gucken
uns die Hintergrundfarbe an.
Geht das?
Kriegen wir irgendwie die Hintergrundfarbe raus von dem Ding?
Weil wenn es grün ist, ist es lagernd.
Nein, lagernd ist nicht. Es gibt auch jetzt
sofort versandfertig, gibt es auch.
Wir müssen die Hintergrundfarbe rauskriegen,
weil das schwierig sein wird.
Woran macht denn das Ding fest, welche
Farbe das hat?
Das hat auch keine CSS.
Doch, das geht mit
crep, mit crep geht alles. Gut, HTML
passen gleich nicht unbedingt. Aber das ist
eigentlich total einfach, wenn ich von dem
div hier feststellen könnte,
wann es grün ist.
Ah,
background-color kommt von
offer-delivery-time.
In dem Fall
Warum hat
offer-delivery-time einmal grün?
Offer-available,
woher gibt es das?
Sehe ich hier nicht.
Wo ist offer-available?
Ah!
Das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Ja klar.
Ach, so ist natürlich nichts available.
Ähm, sondern...
Okay.
Ja gut. Eigentlich...
Doch, das ist dann wirklich einfach.
Wir creppen nach offer-available
und wenn das funktioniert, schicken wir uns eine Mail.
Im Prinzip ist das alles, was wir machen müssen.
Und sobald hier was rauskommt,
schicken wir uns eine Mail.
Das war's
dann eigentlich.
Naja, das war jetzt nicht die hohe Kunst hier.
Aber das wird reichen.
Wie kann man
sagen, dass es quiet sein soll?
Stack-overflop. Ah, minus s,
nicht minus q. Oh man ey, das ist
alles so un... Weißt du, manchmal muss es minus s
sein, manchmal ist minus q quiet.
In dem Fall ist es minus s.
Ewig keine Mail mehr, aber nur eine Zeile verschickt.
Aber wir können es
einfacher machen.
Wobei, wir haben kein
notify installiert.
So in der Richtung könnten wir das dann machen.
Und sobald
das dann quasi verfügbar ist,
kriegen wir eine Mail.
Was jetzt natürlich nicht funktioniert.
Ja. So könnte man
das machen.
Ich hab geguckt,
wie wir uns benachrichtigen
lassen können, sobald
auf... ähm...
Geizhals die neue Intel CPU
da ist.
Ja, das ist mir schon klar,
dass ich das brauche. Hier ist natürlich nix
drauf eingerichtet.
Könnte uns auch ne Discord-Message schicken lassen.
Egal. Ähm...
Fertig
geguckt. Also
eine Sache, die ich jetzt
kapiert habe, dass die Mainboards sich alle
nicht sonderlich viel nehmen.
Dass Gigabyte nicht so
der Fan von optischem TOS-Link
Anschlüssen ist.
Dass ich ungefähr mit
700€ dabei bin, aus meinem
ziemlich... immer noch ziemlich guten System
wieder ein Top-Gaming-High-End-System
zu machen. Und mit das beste
High-End-Gaming-System, was man sich zurzeit
so kaufen kann.
Und ich find, dafür kann man 700€
auch mal investieren.
Ich hoffe, euch hat der Stream gefallen.
Wir machen jetzt Schluss. Ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss was essen.
Und...
Ich würd sagen, macht's gut.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss.